un arlequin tu sais ce que c'est le rôle
de l'arlequin et de services l'arlequin
n'est rien sans son père et tout ce
qu'on pourrait être d'autre les honnêtes
gens s'en tape
[Musique]
le joker moi c'est fini
j'ai voulu tourner la page mais j'étais
pas la seule me fagot tam qui avait
besoin de s'émanciper
vous m'en voyez réjouir et avec
mademoiselle queen elle m'appartient
l'ouzbek qui vous
[Musique]
tu vas comprendre n'a besoin de moi
les à cibler toutes les quatre ont sorti
un parti si vivante
attention c'est serrent les coudes
[Applaudissements]
toi
c'est une blague j'espère trop fun c'est
la soirée pyjama au commande une pizza
en fait des mojitos soit sur le court
mais au coeur
c'est moi qui devrait leur faire peur
bats toi pas monsieur jack je suis avec
où une bande de nazes ou alors ça va on
s'éclate aux pistes mesdames
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses toiles à nanosyn glaymann assez
réducteur créatures j'accepte ou madame
à la rigueur car si je comprends rien
j'aime ça pour moi tu veux